hast du dich gesagt keine schilder
machen sonst gibt es gefängnis selber
die schilder nein das erste schild was
sich insgesamt soll der bekämpfung bak
user ohne back using wird so gar nichts
können
also ich wäre auch dafür dass ein
pendler ich bin das relativ dunkel hier
muss auch gleich schon wieder los
müssen wir nämlich ein zeugnis ja ich
werde ganz so festliche veranstaltung in
der aula oh die ist dass die schüler sie
hat 13 jahre gelernt sehr schön jetzt
die sind fertig und dann ja jetzt habt
ihr ein konzept gebracht ich wollte ich
nur ein bisschen licht haben konnten
wurst großen vulkanisch großen vulkan
chronik was brauchst du eigentlich
hässliche baum fahren
die reaktion war wussten wir benötigten
stärker kürzen
ja ich lasse ihn gleich absichtlich bei
euch noch ein hier vorne hin hat dann
macht es bumm sage ich dir mach dann
mach ich kann auch schon atombomben
bauen damit aber immer schlechter
das ist am arsch thomas mach doch mach
doch mal bei so viel schwachsinn werde
ich die folge lieber mal mein kellers
auf jeden fall schon ein bißchen
vorangeschritten muss die kiste
installieren rand setzen und runter
sortieren und so weiter uns vor das
grundstück grundstück kommen dran
erwarten war
hallo kanzler fliegt und dann muss ich
mir nicht mal ein jetpack holen kann
nicht sein entweder aus mir sehr schwer
da war lange geben bei dir hast du pech
hast jung ist im alter aber wie lange
hat den chefwechsel
was macht also kraft irgendwie oder
ergaunert ich sage mir das projekt table
was bringt project age
wenn sie bleiben die sachen drin wenn du
was kraft ist besseres posten zusätzlich
investor inventar und das bauhaus wenn
du so komplizierte sachen machst hast du
nicht gesagt keine schilder machen sonst
gibt's gefängnis
das erste schild was sich insgesamt
gesetzt
einfach nur froh dass edward gelehrt hat
enttarnten an bord echt nichts ab nur
comstor bisher manchmal ein bisschen
blöd
das geht jetzt hin
auch ein thema ich will aber cholera ein
bisschen kann ich noch engagieren kunden
müssen dann baue ich ägypten okay von
dem einschlag habe ich gibt tipp die
kohle bis jetzt habe ich genau ins eck
abgeordneter beim noch ins text sagen
das ist relativ egal ob beides geht
nicht so oft dass ich diese blöde ich
brenne ich brenne hittfeld für einmal in
einem eimer wasser wasser nein nein nein
nein ich habe mich gefreut ja hast du ja
ja meine kollegin
deine kohle stimmt compressed kräftig
wirklich wirklich wirklich spaß ja ich
möchte aus diesem scheiß coole sachen
hier aus denen hier werden unsere carbon
play day diesen ganzen kohle sachen hier
möchte ich wieder normale kohl das
machen aber ich weiß nicht wie das kind
nicht richtig leicht enttäuschen ich
noch holz natürlich kein holz dabei die
geniale taste danke holz braucht mit
spitzhacken also nein ich komme mir nach
oben glaube ich und zu entwickeln habe
ich etwas vergessen sagen ich mache mir
fackeln ich immer so ja
ob einfach besser machen dann gibt es
noch besser im internet sollen jetzt
kann ich eine tausende carbon platten
machen rau super danke jetzt irgendwie
ziehen die schnauze voll augen
die carbon platt machen sie so ruhig
gefahren der engsten durch
hinten standen wir darauf die von broken
dampf waren das die sind ja schon in der
dings drin
die waren das die sind ja auch schon in
der gekonnt wie drin hier
ok rathmann wurden die dann hinzugefügt
die sind erst um 13 uhr hinzugefügt
worden also das unternehmen geht wieder
kaputt ach so weil die die längste
chains soll die ganze energie braucht
deswegen machen wir machen hier ein
troll bündnis gegen den
falls du es nicht bis jetzt habe ich
bin's nicht hörst du
wochen teil ich ja auf contis mutter du
musst auf dein ich auf meinen du bist du
eigentlich ich bin hier zuhause aber
nicht einstellt ich möchte oder holen
sich kohl haben warte warte weg weg weg
aus raus raus nichts knicks clown leute
gab daneben aber was cloud ich gucke ja
nur gucken und anfassen ist nahe
beieinander
ich hab schon manager zu sagen meine
frau ich gucke ja nur dann bleibst ein
arsch naja im restaurant so geht das du
genau du hast nicht mal kohle doch
klappstühle nein verletzten die zeit für
ein kohlezug nicht krone habe ich gerade
jetzt kurz man sieht abgeschlossen ich
mache innerhalb von sekunden kohle in
der kohle menschen ich gehe mal bei
dieser komischen leiter runter was heißt
da komm ich das ganze mal live my disco
mit exotisch mit einem tollen tag bin
ich ja ok denn genau das vergessen oder
kann hier einfach carbon platten geben
davon nämlich genug jetzt brauche ich
nicht oder parteien generell kein
schwein mehr brauch kabul platten
generator brauchst du ja
ich nehme einfach generator mit und tim
sitzt hin dass sein team das diese kann
in die kernenergie auch so der
kompressor braucht energie gesprochen
aber zehn wieder
christie bereit um einen türken vorbei
oft fiel recht viele ratings audi ist
schon auf fast neben ich sehe mir die
unsichtbar geworden
also die geht immer weiter weil der
druck ist jetzt die da oben oder wie die
ski zu erklären meine mining tool ist
ihr euch geschlagen
es gibt über eine huntington kannst du
leute jagen hab ich gehört aber hier in
kraft wie derzeit also gar nicht geil
redstone hammer ach so und da ich selbst
hab ich die ganzen ärzte japan teil
zack zack zack ich habe glaube ich genug
den sitzen das auch noch gold ja ich
möchte ja ich möchte ja denn ich gebe
die generator du bist mir kohle oder
gold redstone & co kkr kohle- gold- oder
redstone kannst du dir mein generator
ist jetzt ja auch nicht gerade ohne 12
energien
ich war selber kurz nein ich bin auf dem
weg wenn 40 von ihr entfernen ich bin 30
von dir entfernt rief ein
ich bin 20 von dir entfernt ich bin zehn
von dir entfernt ich mal runter ich bin
85 1 6 543 batterie und einem fan ist
ich habe elf generatoren 12 auch keine
mehr ein spaß erst einmal raus in
zukunft aber noch welche ja ja ja okay
kohle gold oder redstone kannst du mir
das sollte erstmal mit glück abbauen
hier ist sich auch gelder letzten halt
die schnauze
gold kann man nicht wirklich nicht er
kommt er kommt kein gold teams aus ach
ja stimmt nur diamanten kohle red stuff
is
die weit von weg
du wirst den weg gelaufen ich 17 22 bis
23 stück generatoren worten steht dir
das hier das kannst du haben
das kannst du haben nur 32 es reicht
doch so was wie viel kohle dass das ist
ich wollte nur angeben so aus spaß aber
gut so er selbst viele gegner noch
merklich jetzt so jetzt muss die
generatoren rainer llp zwischen ich
verteile ich mache nicht beim craften
stocken das macht mich ich will mehr so
gut da gehe ich nicht will trotz mehr
ich hab noch 32 beiden gibt's mehr gibt
es noch hab selber
ich möchte mir du bist du hinten sie
verarschen schon sichtbar geworden
hey du warst nicht mal bei mir also nach
oben
nein einheitlich abschließen nicht
erschließen
nein es ist sind jeden fall in meinem
haus eingang soll jetzt hinter an dir
warte ich möchte später von dem machen
was ihn an der schulter hing komme ich
mal an bestehen
wenn ich jetzt los
nein halt daneben geschossen
warte ich jetzt hier gemacht stefan vor
die sache wird kaputt gehen wenn man
dagegen stieß das förster sehen gegen wo
es so ist denn nun mfs ohne alles für
xamax
im moment alle deswegen sage ich ich
brauche jetzt einfach mal direkt ab weil
der akku sofort alle wo bist du ich bin
hier beste ortsangabe da du klaust mich
ja fast schon dass ich hab so
brauche ich die welt danke so handelt
man liebe freunde sagt mal ab oder
abzocken wie man sie denn mag ist ok
weil ich brauche den und generatoren hin
auch nicht ohne
oder habe ich nicht drauf hast du habe
ich ja jetzt zwölf geothermalen autoren
sitzen energiemenge die bräuchte saddam
hussein für ein widerwärtiges nazis gibt
es keine kultur aber okay hauptsache
sängerin rotary murray gb 4
gold gold gold und nico lied auch die
politik geht nicht im haus der kunst
zeigt so goldrain silbereisen rein handy
co lead geht auch nicht in dings
fairness herrschen damit nikolaus
zeichen ja ich habe kohl und matt stone
ja
handy ein fragezeichen
das war produktiv heute teilweise durch
die gaumen wird teilweise ich bin also
ich mach noch 15 minuten glaube ich ja
ich besuche terminatoren anschließend
mega kraftwerk dann habe ich glaube ich
mache ganz kurzen hat war ich hatte ja
schon mal dass das sind alles abgestürzt
ist deswegen ganz kurzen kette wir sehen
uns dann in der nächsten folge morgen
oder heute noch wieder mit euch gefallen
hat dürft ihr gerne daumen hoch gibt
auch witzig vorbeischauen entsteht nur
beschreiben da seht ihr alt aus seiner
perspektive ist bis zum nächsten mal